welcome to another thankful thursday now
i believe that it's important to think
the people in your life and in your
business who have had an impact to help
you grow so today i want to thank Jason
Jamie toward Jen Christina rich mark and
of course Nina I recently did a video
asking people to impersonate me and
these guys all stepped up an amazing and
hilarious job if you haven't seen the
video yet you should check it out so
thank you so much guys you really made
my day I feel the love and effort that
went into making those videos and it was
an honor to be able to put it up on my
channel for those are you watching take
time today to thank someone who's having
an impact on your business or life send
an email write a note take them up for
coffee doesn't have to cost you anything
just take the time to say thank you
you'll feel great they'll feel great and
you're spreading awesome karma in the
world and remember continue to believe
if you'd like to say thank you to
somebody on this video give them a shout
out in the comments below tag them and
tell them why you really like them and
if you liked this video you want to see
more subscribe to the channel thank you
so much for watching and I'll see you
soon sign up for the newsletter for more
believe
you